Speaker 1: All right, we are going to be talking
today about the Pandora papers much requested
segment that'll be coming up.
I want to start with Facebook, Instagram and
WhatsApp because yesterday Facebook and associated
owned apps and platforms WhatsApp and Instagram
suffered a complete and total outage, their
worst in a very long time.
Just hours after a Facebook whistleblower
was revealed and also made some very, very
disturbing claims about Facebook's awareness
about negative influence on people and society.
But putting, according to the whistleblower,
profit over society, profit over people.
Now are the two stories connected rampant
speculation that the outage was deliberately
put in place by Facebook to prevent those
very platforms from being used to spread the
claims of the whistleblower.
The timing is definitely interesting, for
sure.
There was no denying it.
Although at this point in time, we don't have
anything specific that would tell us that
that's what went on.
Some people are saying, David, what do you
need?
What do you need?
That's more specific.
Let's look at the two stories sort of in tandem.
First and foremost, Facebook whistleblower
revealed on 60 Minutes says the company prioritized
profit over public good would not come as
a surprise to many people that that's what
Facebook did.
If indeed, that is what the whistleblower
observed the identity of the Facebook whistleblower,
who released tens of thousands of pages of
internal research and documents leading to
a firestorm for the social media company in
recent weeks, was revealed on 60 Minutes Sunday
night as Frances Horgan, the 37 year old former
Facebook product manager who worked on civic
integrity issues at the company, says the
documents show that Facebook knows its platforms
are used to spread hate, violence and misinformation,
and that the company has tried to hide that
evidence.
Reminds me of ExxonMobil knowing in the 70s
the impact on the environment that their drilling
activity had very similar vibes.
The thing I saw at Facebook over and over
again was there were conflicts of interest
between what was good for the public and what
was good for Facebook and Facebook over and
over again chose to optimize for its own interests,
like making more money, Hogan told 60 Minutes.
60 Minutes correspondent Scott Pelley quoted
one internal Facebook document as saying quote,
We have evidence from a variety of sources
that hate speech, divisive political speech
and misinformation on Facebook and the family
of apps are affecting societies around the
world.
About a month ago, Horgan filed at least eight
complaints, with the FCC alleging the company
is hiding research about its shortcomings
from investors and the public.
She shared the documents with The Wall Street
Journal, which published a multi-part investigation
showing Facebook was aware of problems with
its apps, including the negative effects of
misinformation and the harm caused, especially
to young girls by Instagram.
If you're interested in that specifically,
check out some of Jonathan Height's work on
the effect of social media, not just on young
people in general, but disproportionately
on young girls, something he's worked on quite
a bit.
Hagen, who started at Facebook in 2019, is
set to testify today before the Senate Subcommittee
on Consumer Protection, Product Safety and
Data Security.
I've seen a bunch of social networks and it
was substantially worse at Facebook than anything
I've seen before.
At some point in twenty one, I realized I'm
going to have to do this in a systemic way
that I'm going to have to get out enough documents
that no one can question.
This is real.
Facebook has pushed back against reports claiming
the claims are misleading and arguing its
apps do more good than harm.
So we're going to get back to that in a moment.
Simultaneously, almost with the unveiling
of this whistleblower Facebook suffering its
worst outage since 2008, pulling down Instagram,
pulling down WhatsApp as well.
Facebook, Instagram and WhatsApp shut down
for more than six hours on Monday.
It marked the worst outage for the tech giant
since 2008, when a bug knocked Facebook offline
for about a day, but the service had only
80 million users back then.
The outage was caused by quote configuration
changes on the backbone routers.
Facebook's VP of Infrastructure Santosh Janardhan,
said in a blog post late Monday.
As of the writing of this article, some of
the services are not yet fully functioning.
For example, some users are still reporting
problems posting new content to Instagram.
All three platforms stopped working shortly
before noon, when websites and apps for Facebook
services were responding with server errors.
Reports on DownDetector dot com showed the
outages appeared to be widespread.
OK, so a bunch of interesting things here.
The first thing is again, are these.
Two stories connected, is this a lie?
Is Facebook just straight up lying?
And they pulled down access to their their
platforms specifically to prevent the spread
of the information about the whistleblower?
I don't know.
I mean, you know, this is one of those things
where there are people who will say, obviously
not, that's obviously not what happened.
Others who will say, of course, that's what
happened.
This is an outage of this degree is so rare
that the idea that it would just be a coincidence
is essentially impossible.
And then people with opinions in between,
I don't know.
All I can tell you is the timing is interesting
now.
What was more interesting is that I missed
nothing from these platforms being down.
And what I mean by that is, OK.
I was working.
I don't really do Facebook during the day.
It didn't affect me negatively in any way
that Facebook, Instagram and WhatsApp were
down for this period of time.
Maybe if it had been a Saturday when I might
just be chatting with people on some of these
platforms, maybe it would have been different.
It did affect our team.
We upload content to these platforms.
We were unable to do so.
It kind of threw for a loop our entire day.
But it is very interesting to get perspective,
sometimes on the importance we believe that
these apps have and then what they really
have when they are missing now.
WhatsApp is relied upon in many countries
as the default messaging app, and I am on
a bunch of WhatsApp threads with people in
other countries, Argentina and elsewhere.
Obviously, those aren't working.
I'm not using that to communicate things of
paramount importance.
Many people are in it, affected them significantly.
Now, Congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
is using what happened yesterday as an opportunity
to say break these companies up.
There's no reason WhatsApp should have to
be down because Facebook is down other than
Facebook bought WhatsApp because it saw WhatsApp
as a competitor.
We will deal with that on the bonus show,
but in the meantime, let me know your thoughts.
Do you see the outage and the whistleblower
unveiling as connected or merely coincidental?